welcome back I don't know what I was
thinking I sometimes my brain
malfunctions but just going back to that
problem doing actually I think we should
do it I'm a little schizophrenic today
so let's figure out the equation for the
volume of a sphere so let's what's the
equation it's x squared plus y squared
is equal to R squared and let's just
write Y is a function of X so we can do
it the way we did that last problem so
you get Y squared is equal to R squared
minus x squared Y is equal to the square
root of R squared minus x squared and
let's draw it so if this is my it's my
y-axis this is my x-axis an equation
draw it straight that's my x axis and
then I actually have a circle tool let
me see if I can use it effectively
Oh close close enough there you go I
think you get the point but anyway this
this is just going to be the upper half
of the circle actually I should probably
just undo that circle tool and try to
draw it by hand so y equals the square
root of R squared minus x squared that's
just going to be the upper half of the
circle so it will be it'll be I'm not
using the right tool this will be this
the positive x quadrant and actually I
should have drawn the whole hemisphere
but anyway so actually let me do that
because I think it'll make edit it undo
let me clear all of this out sorry for
wasting your time but I think it'll be
effective okay so let me redraw so this
that's the y-axis that's my x-axis and
then this it's the square root is since
it's a function it can only have one
value so we assume it's defined as the
positive square root so if we were to
graph that it would look like like this
something like that where this would be
minus R and that's R so if we want to
find the volume of a sphere with radius
R we just have to rotate this this
function around the x axis this is the x
axis that's y axis right so let's see
what we can do so what's let's just
visualize the disks again so let me make
a disc so let's say that that's the side
of one of the disks again and as we know
the depth of the disc is just going to
be DX right that's how wide that disks
is DX and it's radius at any point is f
of X and in this case it's Y is equal to
square root of R squared minus x squared
so what's the surface area of each disc
right what's this the surface area of
each of the disks I hope you know what
I'm saying so area is equal to PI R
squared the radius at any point is equal
to this
radius is equal to Y which is equal to
square root and remember this is not
this R this is the radius of this disc I
know it might be a little confusing but
it will to the square root of R squared
minus x squared so the area is going to
be equal pi times this squared so if you
square this quantity it's just you just
get rid of the square root sign right so
PI R squared minus x squared that's the
area and so what's the volume of that
disk well just like we've done in every
video up to this point the volume of
that disk is just that so the volume of
that disk is just this PI R squared
minus x squared times DX right and so if
we want to figure out the volume of all
these discs right I have a disk here or
a disk here going around round round
round around and they get smaller and
smaller until we have so we'll have a
sphere we just take the integral the
upper bound is positive our lower bound
is minus R and we take the integral of
this expression pi let me distribute it
because that's going to make it easier
PI R squared which is an end which is
just a constant term minus PI x squared
all of that DX so what's the
antiderivative of that expression the
antiderivative with in the parentheses
well this is just a constant term right
PI R squared that's just a number
because we're just taking the integral
with respect to let's say this with
respect to X right so the antiderivative
PI R squared is just PI R squared X
right the derivative of PI R squared X
is just PI R squared minus and we did
this in the last video but actually well
now it's the antiderivative x squared
which is X to the third over 3 so and
the PI is just a constant so pi X to the
third over 3 and we're going to evaluate
that at R and minus R
let me erase some stuff because I'm
running out of space hopefully you all
of that you know by now okay back to the
n tool okay so let's evaluate it at R so
you get so this is PI R squared so PI R
squared and then for X we'll substitute
the positive R times R minus PI X cubed
but now we have this R here so R cubed
over three minus PI R squared PI R
squared and now we have a minus R here
right because we're evaluating the
antiderivative at minus R times minus R
minus PI minus R cube so what's minus R
cubed its R cubed but we'll keep the
minus sign right R cubed and then that -
not let's just make that that will turn
that into a plus over three right let's
see if we can clean this up a little bit
so this is that first term is PI R cubed
right R squared times R PI R cubed minus
essentially 1/3 PI R cubed right and
then what is this this is PI R cubed but
then we have a minus sign up this is
minus PI R cubed and then we have a
minus sign up here so this becomes plus
PI R cubed plus PI R cubed and then this
- and then - because we have a plus here
and then with minus out here so
distribute it so minus 1/3 PI R cubed
and let's see what do we have we have
essentially 1 if we just
distribute out the PI R cube we have PI
R cubed PI R cubed times one minus
one-third plus one minus one-third all
right well let's see that's two two
minus two-thirds or another way see
that's two minus two-thirds this is
turning into a fractions problem and
what's doing well that's six thirds
minus two thirds it equals 4/3 so this
is equal to 4/3 so the volume of the
sphere the volume of the sphere is equal
to 4/3 PI R cubed which is the equation
for the volume of a sphere and actually
now that I realize it did take me 8 and
a half minutes so I am glad am i my
first intuition is always correct I am
glad I did this in a separate video but
that should be pretty interesting to you
and it makes I actually it makes a lot
of sense you know it's going to be a
cube of the radius pi is involved the
4/3 is interesting just you know in
terms of how it relates to everything
else or you know areas PI R squared and
then all of a sudden you get a 4/3 here
so it's something for you to think about
anyway hopefully you found that fun I'll
see you in the next video